In 2021, I sold my e-commerce company,
Prestige Labs, with Gym Launch for $46.2
million. And six months ago, I broke the
Guinness World Record for the fastest
selling non-fiction book and generated
over $16 million in a weekend just using
a Shopify store. And so, in this video,
I'm answering your questions about how
to scale your e-commerce business. And
for all these questions, I try to do my
very best to make the solutions as
tactical as humanly possible so that you
watching from home can immediately use
them. So, enjoy.
>> Hey, Alex.
>> Yes.
>> My name is Max. I run Elevate Customs
with my wife who's in the front row.
It's uh we build
>> Elevate Customs.
>> Yep.
>> Like custom Sorry. Um like uh home
custom solutions.
>> No, we build and sell like luxury gaming
tables like pool tables, casino tables,
manufacturers.
>> Not what I was saying. Okay, got it.
Yeah.
>> Um
>> that's cool. Like cool backlights and
things like that.
>> Yeah. Like any anything like one-off
custom pieces.
>> Sweet.
>> Um we we're at around 2 and a half
million revenue a year. We want to be
around 10. How do you sell at least?
>> Uh, mostly Google ads.
>> So, e-commerce.
>> Yeah, she sells.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, invoices, phone calls.
Okay. Got it.
>> So, how do we increase our leads 2x, 3x
without breaking the bank,
>> basically?
>> How do you increase your lead flow
without breaking the bank?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I'll ask you
>> for quality leads basically.
>> So, what are you currently doing? You
said Google ads.
>> Yeah. Around 15 to 20k a month.
>> Can you spend more?
>> Yeah.
>> Why don't we do that? We've tried and we
weren't generating the same quality
leads or necessarily getting
>> different keywords. We're not getting
you more quality. Yeah, correct. This is
probably a scale thing though. Like this
is a media buying question. Um because I
can promise you that at $20,000 a month,
you haven't saturated the market for
cool custom gaming stuff. Like you could
probably get to like 2 million a month
before you even get close to that. Um so
I think it's probably just a like who
does your media buying?
>> We have a company.
>> Okay. I would this is a keyword thing
like this is this is three degrees down
like super tactical like we're just
buying the wrong words and there's just
we like I would be how what's your
margins right now?
>> 20% 500k a year.
>> So I you just have to see this as like
we might burn $200,000 this year on bad
keywords to find another six that we can
scale up to $100,000 a month and by
doing that we'll 5x the business. And so
if you just see it like that of like,
okay, we're going to spend $200,000 or
$300,000 to take us from 2 whatever to
10. That's how I' that's how I'd think
about it. Um, in general, we tend to be
like scared to spend more money. And I
would say the only thing that's really
shifted for me is like from entrepreneur
to investor, like kind of wearing both
hats, is that I look so much stuff at
just like return on capital and like
what's the point? Like if I think we can
get to 10, I would rather just get to 10
faster. And I see because I don't live
off of that $500,000 a year. I just see
all of that as my my fodder for putting
back into the thing so that I can get to
the next level, which side quest for
everyone. If you're a service business
and you have cash flow, some businesses
are really obvious for where you do
reinvestment. If you're brick and
mortar, you save up your shekeles, you
open another location. Very clear where
your capex goes. If you're
manufacturing, you buy another big
machine, very clear where the capex
goes, right? If you're a service
business, you do accounts, you're have
you have, you know, you have a law firm,
you got uh legal people. What do you do
with the extra money to quote reinvest
in the business? So, there's two primary
sources. Number one is going to be
talent and culture. So, who am I going
to hire? Uh, and how do I how do I
uplevel the team? So, in service
businesses in general, you can see how
good you are and how advanced you are as
a service provider by the by the price
you're able to charge. And so over time
your price should always go up because
fundamentally you should have a virtuous
cycle of we do good work that generates
more demand. More demand means more than
we have supply which means we can raise
the price. With the extra cash we can
then acquire better talent which means
we get we do a better job which
increases our reputation which increases
our price which allows us to charge more
so we can get better talent. And so the
talent should always be going up and so
should the price. And so if you're in a
in a marketplace where you're like man
we can't charge more than other people.
It's because you aren't better than
other people. So we have to beat them in
order like we have to do better. That's
point one. The second area is brand,
right? It's like how do I spend some of
that extra cash to solidify the brand of
me? So this is not direct response ads.
This is like kind of the big
aspirational moments, these brand
moments. Like we just did this launch
this, you know, two weekends ago. It's
like how do I how do I do these big
demonstrations that might cost more and
might not be the normal run of business?
Like why would Red Bull have a guy jump
from out of space down? It doesn't make
any sense, but except it makes a ton of
sense because I'm talking about it right
now, right? And so you're probably more
likely to drink a Red Bull at the break.
Real talk. Uh, and so anyways, it's
like, how does this ladder back to
selling more pool tables? Um, for you
though, you're not in a service based
business per se, but I thought it was a
good offshoot for other people. Um, see
all of the profit that you have,
whatever you don't need to live on as
your experimentation budget. And that
budget is really like do not see it as I
lost money. Like you can't think with
that perspective. You will just lose.
You have to think of that this is like
I'm going to uh rigorously test keywords
until I find more keywords that win. And
these are just investments in finding
money printing machines because keywords
especially once you really find them,
they kind of just print for you, which
you guys are experiencing right now,
right? You got to spend $250,000 a year
to make a 2.2, right? You're getting 10
to1 on it. Now, obviously you have cost
of goods for sure, but like profitable,
right? And I'm sure when you found your
first keyword and it started working,
you were like, "Holy shit." It's like,
"Great. We just need to find like
another hundred." And they're there.
They're there. And you might need bridge
pages. So you've you may have heard of
Eugene Schwarz. Uh so famous marketer.
And so when you really want to scale ads
to colder markets, um for those of you
went through the hooks and the goated
ads, anyone go through goated ads
playbook? Okay. So this this will sound
a little bit more familiar. So you have
these levels of awareness that
correspond with size of market. And so
you've got your most aware customers
here. And the reason that these levels
are important is that it changes what
the hook is and what the kind of click
journey is for the customer. So at the
very top you've got unaware, then you've
got problem aware, you've got solution
aware, you've got product aare, and then
you've got most aware, which is usually
your existing customers, right? And so
if you want to expand, so right now I'll
bet you most your keywords are targeting
these people. If you want to go up
market, which might have 10 times more
clicks, we might have to have a bridge
page after you have like the keyword
might be more like home home projects or
like uh accessor like I' I'd have to
think that I'd use a keyword finder. And
>> would you have like the same team work
on that or hire a completely different
marketing team to kind of
>> a really good media buyer would know
this? Um, but you'll likely just need to
have keywords that are a little bit
broader so you start competing against
more people. But as long as you bring
them to kind of like an advertorial type
page and then they take the next step
and then it basically mimics the same
path as this. It's like you take them
from product aare to then advertorial
then to your sales page. That bridge the
clicks here might also be like onetenth
the price and there's an ocean of them.
And then when you get from there it's
like okay what's what's above that
problem aware? Is your house boring?
Right? Like, do you have an extra room
that you don't know what to do with?
Right? These are problem. They have a
problem. They have no idea that you're
going to sell them a pool table. But we
have to start with where they're at and
then lead them through the journey.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Appreciate it.
>> Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10stage road map from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish. I've now done multiple
times. And so, I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
headcount increases that you need to get
through. And I broke each of these down
by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh, service
businesses, brick-andmortar, all of
this, and it works. And it's my gift to
you. It's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you. All free.
>> Uh, my name is Ethan. Uh, we sell direct
response e-commerce products. We're all
paid media. Uh we do about $3 million a
year in revenue
>> direct response
>> e-commerce products.
>> Okay. Like drop shipping stuff
>> pretty much. Yeah. It's it's more
branded than that, but essentially is.
>> Yeah. So you have customers for doing
that or you're doing that?
>> We're doing that.
>> Okay. Got it. And so you have a handful.
How many SKs do you have?
>> Uh four.
>> Okay. Is it all the same brand?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Yep. So we have uh we're doing it's like
four months old. So, we're doing a run
rate of like uh 3 million a year. Um we
have, you know, background in like paid
traffic affiliate. Um so, it's not the
first rodeo with that. We're trying to
get to like 15 million a year run rate.
>> Okay.
>> Um what's stopping us right now, you
know, not entirely sure, but um
basically like we have each step for
everything that has to be done. We built
out teams and systems for the main
priorities and those things are working
pretty well. I'm happy with uh our
talent, what they're producing. Uh, but
so far what I'm experiencing is that,
you know, I'm left with this, you know,
list of like random chores that somehow
only I can do.
>> A junk drawer. Yeah.
>> But I'm not sure how to approach hiring
for this cuz it ends up being like a
very niche specific task, but I may I
might only need them for like, you know,
20 minutes a week or something. So, it
ends up being me, but with a million
things.
>> And your founder?
>> Uh, yeah.
>> Okay. Um, so let's start here. You want
to get to 15 million. What stops you
from spending more money?
>> Uh, nothing right now. I mean, so we
just hired a pretty robust funnel team
and an operations guy, like a
strategist. So kind of just waiting on
those things to kick in really.
>> Okay.
>> Um, but I'm I'm fairly confident at
least do it.
>> Okay. So this is more a complaint
>> than a constraint, right? No, I'm just
making No, I'm This is me asking for
clarity. So, we think we can double if
we just spend more money. I'm not
spending more money because I'm waiting
for this thing to happen. Once this
thing happens, then I'm going to spend
as much money as I can.
>> Sure.
>> Right. Um and in the meantime, I have
stuff I don't feel like doing, you know?
I'm like, this is me trying to translate
back. Is that true? Is that like
accurate?
>> Yeah. But eventually, there's going to
be enough of that stuff that like I will
have to find some way to hire out for
these things.
>> Yeah. And then there'll be more stuff
that you'll still do.
>> You'll just do the more important
valuable stuff and give the other stuff
to somebody else.
>> Yeah. But a lot of it ends up being
fairly tedious. Like it's it doesn't
feel like high leverage or high value at
all.
>> I mean, this is where like VAS and
product project work can come really in
handy.
>> Like I'll give you an example.
>> So when we made all the ads for the
launch, right? I don't I didn't need the
amount of editors that I had to spin up
in order to because like I'm not going
to be making 300 ads a week, you know,
ongoing. I don't need to. But for the
launch, I did. And I wasn't going to
hire an extra 15 editors full-time
because it's just like I don't need
that. And so we spun up 15 editors that
were contractors who would then just
clip and we had one person just did QA
on it to make sure that it was good and
then we'd ship them, right? And so if we
have something that's like one timeish
work where it's sporadic, then I'm fine
just having a suite or a bench of
contractors that I can turn on and off.
>> Sure.
>> As long as they do decent work.
>> We do similar things like with our with
our video editors as well, but you know,
some of the tasks are fairly specialized
like
>> No, I understand. I was just using
[clears throat] as an example for
editors, but I'm saying like if you have
tedious work like
>> this is where the fivers of the world
like can come in handy
>> and worst case you train a contractor or
VA on how to do it and then they do it.
>> Yeah. Just like someone that's high
level enough in like Shopify work but we
only use them for a few.
>> There's tons of Shopify contractors like
a boatload of them and they're not that
expensive and some of them are really
good.
>> Yeah. I like I would just look at my
list. What are the things I'm doing on a
regular basis? Can I ship out most of
these to a contractor who does a peace
meal? Probably. And now you're trading
20 hours for two. And that's just you
just keep making that trade until
eventually you've managing a ton of
people. And then it's like great, one
person is managing all of these and you
just trade all that time for you getting
more because hopefully if you're doing
that much work, then you should have the
revenue to support um that role. Have
you have you scaled e-commerce like this
before?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Are you are you just running paid
ads?
>> Uh yes.
>> Okay. Do you have influencers who are
doing stuff?
>> No influencers who are looking to hire
for that, but we we have three or four
channels for paid at least.
>> Yeah. I'll say this. How big do you want
this to be?
>> Uh I mean ultimately like the goal is
we'd like to have a portfolio of call it
four or five brands that we can then
exit in a couple years. So, I have this
conversation every week um with somebody
who's doing e-commerce
and it's almost always the same like I
would like to have a portfolio of a
handful of products that I could
eventually sell someday. I have really
yet to see anyone do that. Um and it's I
think for two reasons. One is that as
you continue to scale your CAC will
continue to go up and your gross margins
will shrink and that will get
frustrating. You will then also have
supply chain issues which would become a
burden. You'll also have dupes if you
start becoming really good that will
undercut you in price and list on Amazon
and all that stuff. Um do you have
patent protection like for any of these
products and so like you right now run a
media arbitrage business and it works
really well up to about 10 million.
>> Okay.
>> And then it will quickly stop working
very well. Um and so I think to your
point of like you can see a double
that's probably true. You might even
have a triple that's sitting there with
a little bit optimization, more email
follow-up, blah blah blah blah blah. Um,
but you'll you'll probably get close to
capping in that neighborhood, 10, maybe
12. Um, and then you're going to be
like, well, we're doing a million dollar
a month, but we have like almost no
margin and our cash flow is [__] Um,
and so the what I think you want is that
you want to build a brand that has a
product that you really believe in that
will allow you to recruit affiliates
[snorts] to your cause. When I say
affiliates, I mean influencers, not
traditional direct response uh,
affiliates that are just mercenaries,
but like people actually believe in it.
Um, and when you do that, you will
actually be able to build a brand
because fundamentally like any one of
the products can be big enough on their
own to sell. And so rather than saying
like why don't we try and build four
totally different products and totally
different brands at the same time, it's
like why don't we just try to build one
that we really like that we think has a
chance at actually like really helping
people for whatever the problem that the
the product solves. Um, that's what will
build what I think you want. It's just
that most people who come from the
direct response world just are pure
performance marketers. And I say this
being someone who comes from that world.
And I had to learn the hard way that you
will run into the wall that there's a
there's a great article you can read
called the direct response doom loop
which you might have read. But basically
you just do this revenue goes up,
margins compress, margins compressed
until you're eventually here. And then
you have to keep selling in order to
maintain your team. And then you just
run a very large very high high
liability nonprofit and it sucks. And
cash flow is a huge constraint. and
you've got all the supply chain
[__] And then you're like, "This
sucks." And then you'd have another
conversation, come back here, and be
like, "Hey, we're doing 12 million with
7% margins." And I would say, "Okay, of
the four products you have, which one is
the the one that's the the clear winner?
That's the one that's carrying all the
other losers." And you'd be like, "Well,
it's this one." And then I'd say, "Okay,
cool. Why don't we just get rid of these
three and then put all of your effort on
this? Do you think you'd be able to win
that?" You'd be like, "Oh my god, for
sure." And be like, "Great. So, like,
why don't we do that?" And then actually
invest in building the brand.
>> Yeah.
>> Around it. We we definitely have uh you
know we're we're paid traffic affiliates
so like we're data people like uh but so
one of the things that I've thought
about is like you know our our biggest
skew it it's good but it's not like it's
not that good like I know a good
campaign when I see it. So like part of
the purpose of building out like uh you
know our research and funnel teams is
like
>> well eventually we're going to find
something where the market is just like
10 times better
>> you know so it's like do we keep
chugging along with like the one that's
like a six out of 10 or do we find go
find the nine and then go all in on
that.
>> The skill set that you guys are
deficient in is going to be brand and
that's what you have to learn how to do
and the brand is also completed with the
product
>> right? So like that's what completes the
brand loop. Like we make this amazing
promise, we have all these great
associations. People then make the
purchase and then the product either
reinforces the brand or destroys the
brand. And if it reinforces the brand,
then the loop continues and becomes a
virtuous cycle. And that's how you go
from an e-commerce store that does media
arbitrage into a household name that you
can sell for not just 50 million, but
maybe 500 million. And so it's just that
like I have this conversation literally
every week. And so I know that you're
coming at this from a math perspective.
It's just that it will not work at
scale. And so I would rather you spend
as little as you can on all of these
different things to find a product that
you guys really think is legit and has
some level of defensibility if you can
because if you don't have a defensible
product, the only thing that you have is
the brand to differentiate you. That's
the only differentiator. And so if
you're competing because like just
played out the next step, right? Like
let's say you find your nine out of 10.
No one's buying that. Like private
equity investor not buying it because
they know the game. They buy brands.
They don't buy products and so you get
your nine out of 10 and then the dupes
flood because they see that you're
killing it and then they undercut you on
all this stuff and then your rorowes
goes down and then you leak everything
to your competitors. So either you have
some sort of patent that you can
actually protect and you have a legal
team that can enforce it or you build a
brand. So like that's the long-term
play. The rest of this is just making
money until you figure that out. I'm
being super real with you. I just rather
save you a couple years.
>> But like that is where this leads.
>> Okay. I I mean so
>> how do you build a brand?
>> Yeah. Right. [laughter]
>> Yeah. How do how do I do that? But um
you know we are working on like the
legal defensibility of it. You know I I
didn't mean to say like
>> I would lead with brand rather than
making
legal.
>> Yeah.
>> Because legal you have to like it's
still tough to like it's it's better to
be big and then win with legal than try
and be small and win with legal because
you'll just get drowned in fees. And
it's it's it's better to just have the
coolest brand and have the coolest
people promoting the thing and then
people just want to buy from you even
though they see the cheaper knockoffs.
But that's like that's what you have to
do if you really want to go where you
want to go. Otherwise, you're just going
to be cycling through SKs and you're
going to say you have a portfolio and
it'll sound impressive to people who
don't know what you're talking about,
but like margins will do this, cash flow
get [__] and you have co-founders and
it'll be like this is so much work. This
sucks. [laughter] I wish we had one
product that we all really believed in
that we could like build a business
around.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what you want to do.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. You bet.
>> Hi, my name is Samantha Harrison. I own
a hair extension company in Australia.
>> Amazing.
>> I have a salon and an e-commerce
business.
>> Oh, what? In e-commerce?
>> Sorry. Sorry. I wholesale.
>> Wholesale and e-commerce. So, direct to
consumer and wholesale.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Got it.
>> Um, sorry. I'm like so nervous. I have
terrible fear of public speaking. have a
panic attack and then just ask a
question. You're good. [laughter]
>> I forgot what my question was.
>> Fine.
>> Um, read what I wrote down if that's
okay. [laughter]
>> Okay. So, to make either business truly
sellable at high valuation, it would
take me years of operational
restructuring, recruitment, reducing
owner dependence, and building systems.
And even then the multiple would be low
because service based product businesses
don't scale without heavy ongoing input.
I want to
move into SAS.
>> You think you think this is hard and so
you're like you know what I could do
something harder.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> And so I guess that was the point of me
coming to this seminar cuz I know you
talk a lot about like the women in the
red dress.
>> Yeah. Or men in the tuxedo, you know,
whatever works.
Um, obviously I'm fearful cuz it's not
my niche and it's not what I specialize
in, but I obviously being in the
industry, I definitely see a lack in the
market and education.
>> So, what is the SAS that you're trying
to build or that you
>> It's an online booking system for well,
the niche is for salons, but it can be
used for service- based businesses.
>> There's so many of those.
>> It's got AI built into it. And the the
difference between mine and say
everybody else's is it's essentially
bridging the gap between revenue and
profit. So giving like more of like a
pull data rather than push. Um having
the AI built in as more as like a
motivational business coach which will
give you the real time analytics on your
team,
>> on your services, on your numbers, on
your margins, like everything like that.
Like for me personally, I spend every
week calculating every single team
member's revenue, cost of product.
>> You own a salon, too?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> But the So the salon and the wholesale
run without me.
>> Okay.
>> The salon does about So the salon does
about say 900,000 with 50% margin
>> and I'm happy with like what like I
don't really want to scale the salon.
The wholesale year, well this year has
grown 100% but it's about 30% month on
month.
>> What was the revenue of the wholesale?
Um I think I'm just at 2.6. Okay. So
far.
>> Um
>> and you have 30% margins on that.
>> Yeah.
>> Great.
>> So the financial overview for this SAS,
so it's $500,000 build,
120 grand a year to maintain, but it's
serving my same audience, right? The the
stockists are already salon owners. They
already buy from me. They already trust
me. It's something that they want use,
have already subscribed to like the
founders. Don't look at me like that.
Believe in me. [laughter]
>> I do. I do.
>> I'm just trying to figure out which you
believe in.
>> I'd only [laughter] need 150 subscribers
to maintain costs, which I've already
got.
>> So, if I had 2,000 of my weekly stockers
that already buy from me, subscribe,
there's 2 million a year. It's fine,
right? Tell me it's a good idea, please.
[laughter]
There's so much pain.
>> You sound like Ed. [laughter]
>> I've been sulking all day.
>> So, one of the difficulties that I have
like this is a is a perfect scenario of
um telling someone what they want to
hear versus telling them what I think.
And I uh I'm always it's very fine line
because like I always want everyone to
leave happy. Um but I also feel like I
have integrity. Tough, right? Um, and
so, um, I I what I will do is I will
give you a sorting question. You can
pick what side you want.
>> Okay?
>> I can assume your position and then tell
you what I would do, although I disagree
with it, or I can tell you what I think
you should do.
>> Okay.
>> Which one would you like?
>> Tell me what I should do.
>> Okay, [laughter] great. Um, I think that
>> I'm going [laughter]
>> I think you getting into SAS as somebody
who has never built a software product
and doing it where you're going to
self-fund it. Um, and just because you
have a distribution base does not mean
that you should sell every single thing
that that distrib distribution base can
buy.
>> What if I've already paid for it?
>> That's called sunk cost fallacy.
[laughter]
>> Okay, for real.
>> So, I just give up. I don't try. Just
walk.
>> Some of the best money you ever spend is
deciding to stop spending bad money.
Okay.
>> Um, and I say this only having done it
myself. Um,
so I'm gonna I'm I'm gonna hit from a
couple angles. So the first one is who
here is organic as their primary method
of getting customers like making
content, etc. And it gets bigger and
bigger every time. It's just the way
it's it's the way the world's roving.
Um, so one of the big mistakes that
people who have organic audiences make
is that you grow an audience and then
you sell a product and then people buy
the product and you make money and
that's a very reinforcing event. And so
then but they already bought the
product. So then you think well [__] I
should make another product and so you
make another product and then within two
or three years all of a sudden you have
four mini businesses that serve the same
pool of customers when the real
constraint of the business is you needed
to grow your audience. And so the
invisible be or sorry not the extensions
whatever it is that you sell right the
the hair extensions that you sell uh
you're doing you know 2.6 and what's the
what's the e-commerce side doing in
revenue?
>> Yeah it's like 900
>> 900 that's what it's doing.
>> Sorry. Sorry. The the salon is 900. The
online is 2.6.
>> So, okay. So, there is no you said
e-commerce at some point.
>> Yeah. So, e e-commerce I'm selling
online is the wholesaling. Okay. Got it.
It's
>> B2B. I also sell to retail wholesale and
retail. So, anyone can buy, but I do
have stockist.
>> The vast majority is other stylist
buying.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> So, can buy from me, but also hair
extension salon owners can register for
a trade account.
>> And how many of the sales are trade
accounts?
>> It's about 50% at the moment. is
interesting. Okay. So, um anyways, back
to this point which is that
>> that business is not not sellable. I
just want to be like you you said like
ready you started you're like it's not
sellable. It's operation blah blah. It's
like that's I mean not necessarily true
kind of at all. Yeah.
>> Um, you just need to get more customers
and extensions are a reoccurring
product. Like people buy them every 8
whatever the weeks are, you know,
whatever the you know it better than I
do,
>> but I know I've seen the bill. So,
[laughter]
>> it's not one time.
>> I think
>> I'm sure about that. So, so all that to
say like all we have to do is just like
we you have now encountered the big
hairy problem that I talked about at the
beginning of today which is that you
encountered something that you didn't
know how to solve and then are thinking
okay well there's greener pasture over
here there's a girl in a redder dress
and if I go here surely this grass will
not be fertilized with [__] um but it is
indeed full of [__] and significantly
more [__] than what your current
business is the current business is
actually way more chill than the
business that you're trying to get into
and the business you currently have is
way more cash positive than the one you
want to get into the business that you
want to get into, you will not make
money from for many years, if you ever
make money from it. So, if you want to
win at software, you have to commit to
making no money for basically seven
years. Zero. And the people you're
competing against don't have two other
businesses.
>> I guess like my limiting belief around
like I've got a very lean business. So,
I built a property a couple of years
ago. I ended up moving out and I run the
wholesale and the salon from that house.
So, my expense for the salon and the
wholesale is 500 bucks a week. So, it's
very lean. Yeah.
>> So good.
I'm like
obviously on the extension side. You
mean
>> Yeah. Like my margins are too small for
me to be able to scale at the margins
that
>> So why don't we just do that?
>> I'm like if I can
>> because you thought starting a software
company. I well I thought that having
like a risk uh sorry a reoccurring
>> you have a reoccurring business
>> based product that I would use as well
>> so
reoccurring and recurring right have the
same value what we need to demonstrate
is revenue retention
>> I would just like to make money online
while I sleep and I don't want to work
anymore
>> that's fine software companies is
certainly not the way to do it
[laughter]
>> probably the worst way to try and do
that
>> okay
>> um like we just need to confront the
business that you have right now, you
need to improve the margins and you need
to go get more acquisition. So that
probably means like making more content,
running ads to attract uh stylists,
having some sort of offset front end to
get them integrated. How can you run
some sort of play within their you know
salons?
um trying to use [snorts] your your
vernacular um to you know basically make
them more money using your extensions
and then by doing that then they get
converted because they make more money
selling extensions than cutting color
and so it's very likely they'll keep
selling it and then you have basically
you have a hunter and a farmer the
hunter is the one that basically closes
the deal and gets them to kind of
activate their base of of um ladies I
guess I maybe there's guy
>> it's just like the constraint of the
wholesale is the production time and the
capital
>> um And again, like my logic was, well,
if I was to invest the same $500,000
into the wholesale, that's a $150,000
margin. Whereas I thought, well, if I
invested it into subscriptions,
>> you would just lose all of it.
[laughter]
>> Maybe that's your limiting belief.
>> I've built more software companies to a
billion than you have.
[laughter]
>> Fair. Okay.
>> Right. Two can play that game.
Okay.
>> Do you want my help?
>> Yes.
>> Take my advice.
>> Okay.
>> Cool.
>> I should do it.
>> Thank you.
>> My name is Sasha. Um I sell designer
bags and sunglasses and uh we do about 6
million a month. No, sorry. A year.
Sorry. 6 million a year.
>> So cool.
>> Um and I would like to do 38 million
>> precise.
>> Yeah. 38 million.
>> Okay.
>> Um and what's stopping me is recruiting.
Why 38?
>> Um just because I figured, you know,
100,000 a day, something like that.
Round up, down, something like that.
>> Okay.
>> Just a roundabout. Um and um I mean,
obviously more.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> But
>> I was thinking 38 would be fair.
>> Yeah, that works.
>> Um [laughter]
>> and it is just recruiting. Um
>> recruit Oh, recruiting is the bottom
line as you're saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, got Um, my house cleaner was my uh
first employee and she just and because
I consumed yours and Leila's content so
much that
>> I was like, I'm going to be these two
people in one. That's me. I'm going be
these two people.
>> And as a result, I have um
>> a great team, a really great team. And
it's just a matter of being militant in
the um the recruiting process.
>> Okay.
>> Um
the we do sell on whatnot quite a bit.
>> So, who do you have what's stopping you?
So you make money $6 million a year
selling handbags
>> and sunglasses. [clears throat]
>> And sunglasses. For you to sell more
handbags and sunglasses, you need more
people to do that.
>> Yes. Because we u we only go live for
about 5 hours a day because we get
tired. It's just me and Well, me and um
I have three sales people, but um it's
just we get tired. We could if we were
live more often, we could create more.
You're going live on like your Instagram
page or your what?
>> On whatnot.
>> Okay, got it. And do you have like a big
following there?
>> 110,000. Ton of
>> And so you're just selling to that same
base [snorts] and if you just sold for
longer, you would make more.
>> A lot more. I could do 100 grand in the
show.
>> Okay. So you just need like two more
sales people who go on camera.
>> Mhm. But yeah. Mhm. And then the
recruiting as well.
>> Recruiting for what? uh packing because
we we do a lot of um
>> you do your own 3PL or not third party
but like you do your own logistics.
>> H why
>> why do we do it ourselves?
>> I didn't I didn't know you could have
other people do it.
>> Boy oh boy. Yeah. [laughter]
>> Step inside. Uh yes. [laughter]
So so functionally like because of the
nature of the business that you're in um
we have to think like we have to we have
to consolidate resources. I'm not
normally somebody who's like, uh, let's
let's cut, you know, parts of the
business out, but unless your shipping
is some key differentiator that you
have, uh, like Amazon shipping became a
competitive advantage, right? Um, but
unless that's like some differentiator,
then shipping for the most part is
pretty commoditized. And there are
people who all day long they think about
like saving 15 cents on cardboard boxes
and tape and packing peanuts and all
that [__] Um, and I think that that you
having to like think about that and run
a functionally a warehouse at the same
time as running a marketing and sales
and talent business/media.
That's not where the value is. The value
is in the distribution and the sales.
And so I would say like can we outsource
this so that can [snorts] we outsource
this the the logistics part so that you
can just go all in because all we had to
do is you get two more sales people and
you get to 100,000 a day. We should do
that.
>> So um we have to physically show the
product like
>> No, I'm not saying you don't have like
some product on hand. You just don't
need a warehouse. No, we do need it cuz
it's like go go go go
speed. We run probably about
>> So you're like we sold this item to this
person is how you do it.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So
>> um Got it.
>> It is kind of like a warehouse. It's
Yeah.
>> Okay, that's fine. Um All right. So you
just need to hire more people. So what's
stopping you from hiring more people?
>> The talent. Um
>> the talent to hire more people.
>> Well, I'm I'm learning now. That's why
I'm here.
>> No, no, you're good. You're good. Um,
>> so I'm saying like you have two sets of
roles. You've got warehouse folks and
you've got people who can get on camera,
right? So what are you currently doing
to get each of those people?
>> Well, we had ads on Indeed.
>> Okay.
>> But I didn't realize how militant I had
to be until I came here.
>> It's it makes a lot of sense, right? I
didn't know that there's that many
interviews that were required.
>> Um,
>> and that's more for the warehouse side,
correct?
both because sales is
>> I think that you'd be able to find
salespeople like I would probably look
at Amazon affiliates.
>> How much would you pay them?
>> Percentage.
>> Well, that's the thing now. So, okay.
So, it takes skill to do what we do.
>> Yeah.
>> It takes skill. Like
>> Agreed. [laughter]
>> Like um for example, my girl is better
than me.
>> Great.
>> She's better than me. And it's like
not only is it motor skills, it's um
presentation and entertainment.
>> I I get it. [laughter]
I understand. I did a live for 3 days. I
got it. [laughter]
>> Um so finding and training that um
that's definitely a process and takes
time.
>> Yeah. The question is whether you want
to buy or build.
>> Do you want to buy the town or build the
town? Building the town is cheaper,
takes longer, harder. Buying the town is
faster, more expensive. Which one do you
Which one feels right for you?
>> So, when it comes to the So, we have um
we're not always So, we are profitable
per show. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Profitable per show.
>> But sometimes what ends up happening is
like let's just say it's a a Wednesday,
right?
>> Are you on cash based accounting or
acrruel?
>> Probably cash.
>> Yeah. So you might like if basically if
you run a physical products business
which you do here
>> you're like okay we made money now let's
take all of that profit gross profit
that we had and go buy more [__] so we
can sell more [__] right
>> right so this is where like you probably
have what's your like what's your
financial the financial side of the
business the financial ops look like
>> my accountant handles it
>> your who
>> my accountant
>> oh your accountant does it okay
>> you will need to have soon a relatively
strong finance person
>> uh who can give you better forecasting
so that you can it's not just like how
much cash we have in the bank account,
let's go buy more [__] It's like we can
only afford to buy this much given this
growth rate that we want to have.
>> Mhm.
>> Um otherwise you will get into these
probably cash crunches that you're
feeling right now. It's not that the
business isn't profitable cuz I'm
guessing the headcount's not super. So,
so our so our shows will make anywhere
from like 5 to 7,000 in profit depending
on like the volume that we did that day.
So, we know the profit like per show.
However, um
>> that's where the skill comes into play.
Like if a show is not going well, we
need to have that person trained to be
able to do the do the thing and and so
that's why not knowing how much to pay
them is the
>> Well, I mean, I think doing a percentage
would make sense.
>> Percentage of profit.
>> Yeah. Like a salesperson.
>> Okay. And so you can buy or build that,
right? So you buy it as I would just go
to many micro influencers who are
already like on Amazon hawking stuff and
be like, "Well, they already do live
streams and they already do sell [__]
and I bet I could teach them to do this
for me." That is a buy version because
you already know it's already proven.
You're just saying, "Hey, do it under my
umbrella." The build version is that you
have to kiss a lot more toads and try
and look for who has
already built in a bunch of soft skills.
>> Mhm. And then you can hire for the
smallest skilled efficiency that you
know how to train.
>> Okay. So, Amazon affiliates.
>> Well, you can do either, but like Yeah.
I mean, obviously this is going to be a
lower risk thing and then you just have
to have some agreement that they're
going to only sell for you for x period
of time.
>> Mhm. Like a contract. Yeah.
>> Like a contract.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes.
>> But I would but big picture because I
want to make sure that you're good. Um
the indeed warehouse stuff that's just
like commoditized. I mean you have a
warehouse, maybe you have to have it for
your business, but like I don't see that
as like that's not a core
differentiator. You might h you're not
different because you have a warehouse
behind you.
>> That's not special. So the roles that
you have there, it's like they need to
be like have a pulse, have a good leader
there, let them just deal with it. Your
your star factor is going to be your
ability to train people to sell.
>> Mhm.
>> And so that's like where is your what is
like what is the true pinpoint of where
the most value gets created for you as
the founder, the entrepreneur is that
you need to be able to take somebody and
teach them to sell.
>> I Yeah. Um my
>> and you have to break it down in in
terms of the most concrete language you
possibly can. And so think of everything
purely in terms of behavior and do do
not use any amorphous words. So and like
I need you to have higher energy. That
means nothing. I need you to raise your
voice. I need you to talk faster. I need
you to have your shoulders back. You
have to describe things that people can
see and then other people will describe
them as having high energy, having
charisma, having confidence. And so if
you want to teach someone to present,
you have to tell them what to do with
their body and their voice and it will
be far faster for you. And what you'll
find is the training lap, the reason it
takes so long for people to train or
they can or they can't train sales
people or presentation people is because
they literally do not use words that
other people understand. Like this is
the problem. This is why most companies
cannot teach people to do [__] because
they say have more charisma and then the
person listens and it's like I'll
translate that into what I think
charisma means which who [__] knows
what they think it means right and then
we're just playing this telephone game
where no one agreed on what are the
behaviors I want you to do that will
compress the amount of time that it will
take you to get some one up to speed and
two long term if you can develop this
sales training then you can have a
stable of stallions that are on 247 for
you working in your in your barn
So that
>> I don't know why it's animals now, but
let's go with it.
>> So that that's actually that brings up
the a good point. So [laughter] I I I
have um so my girl, like I said, she's
my house cleaner, shows up at my my door
one day. She's
>> she's like, "Hey, I want to be you."
>> Yeah.
>> And she's like, "I'm a copy and paste of
you." And she became me.
>> Yeah.
>> Now there's a little bit like a little
bit of a how can I cuz obviously I had
to learn the care part like from Leila.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, so I learned to care a part. Um,
[laughter] and um, now I have it, but
then I've seen her I mean I've seen
situations kind of like not go the way
they should because she's too she's a
copy and paste of me from yesterday.
>> Uhhuh.
>> So um, I'm starting to see those.
>> What's the problem?
>> Human put her in front of the camera,
have her sell, and get her out of the
building if like if she can sell.
>> Yeah.
>> So let her sell. Don't have her manage
people, have her sell.
>> Got it. Understood. Thank you.
[laughter]
>> This is good talk. Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Real quick, I have a gift for you. This
is the $100 million scaling road map.
It's something that my team and I put
200 plus hours into building and
breaking the stages of scaling into 10
steps. All right. And so what we did is
we broke down everything that got us
basically got us stuck and what we did
to break free at each level of the
business. And if you'd like to know what
product, marketing, sales, customer
service, IT, recruiting, human uh
resources, and finance look like at the
stage that you're currently at, this is
a free gift. So all you have to do is go
to aquis.com/romap. You can plug in your
business information. And if you want
our help, you want my help to help you
break through whatever level of scaling
you're at. This is not a promise. I'm
just saying I'd love to help. Um on the
thank you page, you can book a call. Uh
every month we have a workshop out here
at my headquarters. She actually talked
to my real team that does does our
marketing, does our emails, does our
ads, does our copy, does our does our
does our sales, does our finance, does
our recruiting. The real people are
doing this at a very high level. And
what's really cool about that is that
they can typically find and spot what
the constraints are in a business like
that. And so it's one of the most
valuable things that I could possibly
do. Obviously, you know, space is
limited based on our actual
headquarters. Um, but if that's
interesting, on the thank you page, you
can book a call. No pressure. This is a
gift either way. It's absolutely free.